Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P I got a voicemail
from a guy who he calls pretty frequently.
He seems to think I'm still talking about
Bernie Sanders now. I supported Bernie twice.
I believe that Bernie's time has come and
gone. I don't think Bernie's even thinking
about running in 2024. I haven't talked about
Bernie in months, but here's a caller who
seems to be under the impression. That I'm
still talking about, Bernie.
Speaker 2: I still haven't figured out what
motivates you to constantly downplay Bernie's
ability to get into the White House. He would
have easily gotten into the White House except
for the fact that he's an actual economic
and social populist. Okay.
Speaker 1: So a couple different things here.
First of all, I've already gone through the
math. It's very popular to say. Bernie definitely
would have beaten Trump had he been the nominee
in 2016. I have not actually seen the evidence
of that. I voted for the guy in the primary
in 2016. I have not actually seen a compelling
mathematical case made for why Bernie would
definitely have defeated Trump in 2016, where
Hillary did not. Bernie couldn't even win
the primary. Well, it's because the DNC. Okay.
Yes, to some degree that's true. But I have
just simply not seen the math of that.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump wasn't. Donald Trump
hijacked some of attorneys economic talking
points. You know that. Donald Trump received
an inordinate amount of artificial help. Otherwise,
the American people would.
Speaker 4: Have never voted for a lifelong
con.
Speaker 2: Man in career criminal and fast
talker and actually like Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Part of me, it sounds like this
guy stuck six years ago. I think he's talking
more about 2016 than 2020. Guys, I got it.
We're going to listen to a little more of
this. I have to tell you, I don't know why
I'm getting a phone call about this. I haven't
mentioned Bernie even in passing in months.
And it seems like this caller is talking about
a six year old election.
Speaker 2: She didn't win the popular vote.
He got in here with that stupid rally called
the Electoral College.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we know that. And that's
not unique to Trump.
Speaker 2: You and I both know that. Has there
anything given an honest level playing field
to compete with? He would have easily won
the White House. We both know that.
Speaker 1: I just don't know that.
Speaker 2: Be honest with yourself. Donald
Trump received an inordinate amount of help.
He received help from the corporate media,
from the leadership of the Democratic Party.
That's right. And, of course, the Republican
Party.
Speaker 1: Listen, there's another minute
and a half to this voicemail. I'm not going
to play it. I don't fully understand whether
the issue is this guy thinks I've been talking
about Bernie. Or that this guy is still rehashing
a six year old election? Yes. We look at history
to understand what what is going on and and
to understand the future. Of course, I understand
that. But I just don't really know what's
going on. And it's worrying me a little bit.
Let me know what you think. Always, always
welcome all calls. But sometimes speech has
consequences. And it might be me wondering
what the hell is going on. We have a great
bonus show for you today. We have been following
the World Cup in Qatar, Qatar, Qatar. Everybody
has a different pronunciation. Okay. That's
not what the issue is. Someone ran onto the
field with a rainbow flag during the match
between Portugal and Uruguay. Uruguay. Please,
folks. One of my favorite teams, by the way.
And this, of course, relates to a lot of the
extreme right wing insanity of Qatar. We're
going to talk about it on the bonus show.
Number two, San Francisco is considering a
law that would allow law enforcement robots
to use lethal force. Is that a good idea?
It's sounding like a very bad idea. We're
going to talk about it. And thirdly, a Florida
woman has sued Velveeta, claiming that its
macaroni takes longer than three and a half
minutes. What does that make any sense? What
are the damages? Well, we're going to talk
about all of it and more on today's bonus
show. Ladies and gentlemen, please get the
bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, it makes money to fund the
show and pay salaries and pay health insurance
and do the things that good employers try
to do.
Speaker 4: Alex, thank your lucky stars every
day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Well, that's fine. I fortunately,
I don't have $1,000,000,000 settlement against
me. Bonus show join pacman dot com. You sign
up, you get instant access. And again, I want
to remind you, we have a new free offering.
It's all funded by the same membership program
we have. And I believe it's an eight or nine
page white paper. Building arguments without
burning bridges. People call in. I can hear
them crying. They have tears. They say, David,
I need to talk to my crazy uncle about his
right wing politics, but I don't want to ruin
the relationship. We have a guide for how
to talk about politics with people and how
to at least get them to reconsider their views.
It is free. It is completely free at David
Pakman dot com slash guide. We will see you
on the bonus show and back here tomorrow.